welcome back to cbs saturday morning we
begin this half hour with a man who's
taken more than his fair share of life's
hard knocks yet still comes up smiling
leon coffee is a star of the rodeo
circuit a clown whose job is serious
business keeping animals distracted so
others in the ring can stay safe and
it's earned him some much deserved
recognition janet schamlian has more
[Music]
bull riding has been called the most
dangerous eight seconds in sports
but it's the bull fighter also known as
a rodeo clown right there in the ring
for distraction who frequently takes the
hardest hit
[Applause]
few know how that feels more than leon
coffee now in his fourth decade of aches
and pains tell me
what hurts the most
other than your pride every time you get
hit he started as a bull rider but for
most of his career has been on the other
side
saving their hives i heard you've broken
a few bones
you heard it
yeah couple dozen what would you put the
number at
141.
i've had my neck broke my back broke
14 knee surgeries
this steel barrel patted inside is what
coffee jokingly calls his office you got
to be in down and around
and he was happy giddy almost here we go
to offer a taste of what it's like
inside
that's a little different ain't it
but that quick trip is nothing compared
to being inside when a 1500 pound bull
gets a bit ornery that bull decided to
go knock leon in his barrel over before
he left the arena what see
[Music]
just barely rolled him you're a tough
old gun aren't you
[Music]
in line between bravery and idiocy
i just erased the line
the ritual of putting on his makeup and
clown clothes hasn't changed for years
but now in his late 60s coffee has moved
a bit back from the chaos though still
center stage
he's rodeo royalty named to its hall of
fame in 2018. me and my brother are
always excited to see you we have this
tradition where we'll be like it's we
own coffee
a celebrity on the circuit especially
among children
just right thank you a duty he takes as
seriously is facing down a raging bull
kids and clowns are synonymous
so once you put that makeup on you've
got to assume that responsibility
a master of the arena in the clothing of
a clown whose work
is no joke
will you stop getting in that can
anytime soon anytime soon
do you know something i don't
[Laughter]
for cbs saturday morning i'm janet
chamlion in houston
oh my gosh i love his laughs that laugh
it's the best he's gonna try to recreate
it but nobody
he's so ornery
very good